ever wondered how to make a cool couple
of million dollars well one option would
be to sharpen your bidding skills and
join the cast of storage wars power
couple brandi passante and jarrod schulz
have raked in a small fortune while
bidding on storage units for the A&E
reality show the pair were original cast
members on storage wars which first
began in 2010 after this they became so
popular with fans and producers alike
that in 2014 they were given their own
spin-off Brandi and Jarrod married to
the job which followed their lives as
they juggled their personal dealings
with their work sadly that spinoff
lasted for only eight episodes and
passante and Schultz decided not to
continue for a second season the two
last appeared on the original storage
wars in March 2018 calling it quits
after eleven seasons and many many high
stakes bids these days the couple each
maintain a much lower profile having
been able to give up the spotlight
thanks to the huge stacks of cash they
raked in during their time on storage
wars but just how much money are brandi
passante and jarrod schulz worth today
according to celebrity net worth the
Santa's net worth hit the 2 million
dollar mark in 2019 while Schultz is
reportedly also worth approximately 2
million dollars of course brandi
passante and jarrod schulz wouldn't be
worth several million dollars today if
they hadn't landed the roles on storage
wars their involvement on the beloved
ane show reportedly came after Schultz's
aunts encouraged him to get into the
storage auction business at one auction
Schultz met the storage worst producers
and eight months later they arrived at
his info Santa's antique store to
recruit him after subsequently meeting
passante the same producers decided to
bring her in to but Santana Schultz his
playful Pickering quickly won over fans
of the show in particular passante is
bright demeanor made her a firm fan
favorite wall Schultz his tendency
toward impulsive bidding blended well
with his partners more cautious brand of
buying in fact there was a good reason
passante kept cautious while bidding on
storage wars because passante knew
nothing about auctions before she was
cast the whole game was more Schultz's
wheelhouse but the storage wars
producers recruited her anyway
presumably because they were so taken
with the pair's chemistry obviously it's
clear that decision more than paid off
for both the show's team and for
passante and Schultz themselves in the
early days of storage wars the cast was
reportedly paid $2,000 per episode as
show grew in popularity however those
salaries skyrocketed particularly for
the original cast by the time passante
and Schultz left storage wars they were
each our name $15,000 per episode during
their spin-off it was reported that
passante earned around $12,000 per
episode
at the same time Schultz was earning a
total of around 58 thousand dollars per
month passante and Schultz his financial
fortunes even blossom despite the fact
that the second branch of their now and
then antique store never turned a profit
when the couple were recruited to the
show they had already opened a store in
Orange California during the pair's
stint on the show they opened a second
location in Long Beach sadly since then
both stores have closed down one in 2014
and one in early 2019 this feels like
some bad juju voodoo beyond the show and
their antique stores much of the
couple's success comes from their other
business ventures for example passante
and Schultz run another store called
outlaw apparel which sells a range of
clothing and accessories the store
opened in 2009 a year before storage war
started who has Schultz himself taken on
an important role in the design process
for much of the brand's clothing today
with passante and Schultz seemingly
retired from the reality TV game the
couple seemed to be enjoying a more
low-key way of life
unfortunately in 2019 Schultz stopped
appearing at po Santa's Instagram posts
leading to speculation that the couple
may have split although this hasn't been
confirmed did no doubt be a tragic end
for one of reality televisions most
successful couples check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]